qu'on soit quand même que les autorités
prennent note de notre perte sèche elle
serait ce que au niveau des impôts qu'on
sache que nous avons quand même des
changes pour l'entretien pour la
entretien d'arthur notre santé au niveau
et récits et il ya beaucoup de publicité
dans les avions pour le tcsp
il n'y a aucune reconnaissance
publicitaire pour nous alors que nous
sommes
professionnel depuis mathusalem vers le
haut et de plus en plus nous sommes afin
de disparaître à cause de ces moyens de
transport nous moderniser donc les
toilettes quand même que les autorités
nous acceptons d'une table ronde pouvoir
pour moi nous aider a quand même non
oui organisée sur le plan de l'aéroport
même sur le plan du porc parce que ces
mêmes circuits touristiques et là nous
sommes en train de le sauver
financièrement ça nous inquiète
énormément on a des nouveaux collègues
qui a un client vraiment des dettes
parce qu'ils ont acheté des licences
ils ont acheté des voitures neuves et
de très gros problèmes a quand même
réuni parce qu'ils ont des dettes auprès
de la banque
ils ont quand même
besoin de vivre donc tous ses nouveaux
collègues qui travaillent avec nous
en france inquiets pour eux parce que
avec les tcsp en perdrait pas vraiment
trop de notre chiffre d'affaires